das ist kelsey und das bist janus und
das ist der aufstand in der nähe von
unserem büro
wir stellen euch heute verschiedene
obstsorten auf deutsch form
das ist ein apfel
das ist eine banane janisch meist in den
apfel
chelsea macht eine banane mampfen ist
ein umgangssprachlicher sword für essen
janisch zählt eine apfelsine chelsea mag
es nicht apfelsinen zu stehlen
davon werden die finger immer klebrig
chelsea mag aber gerne apfelsinen
deshalb muss ja noch die apfelsine für
sie schälen
das ist eine melone es gibt honigmelonen
wassermelonen netz melonen und andere
melonen janosch teilt die melone mit
einem messer die melone tropft auf den
boden
das sind weintrauben
chelsea ist weintrauben
das ist eine birne mechanisch zählt die
birne und teilt sie in vier stücke
das sind himbeeren chelsea das gerne
himbeeren
das sind wäre
erdbeeren sind besonders im frühling
beliebt janus liebt grapefruit ja
michelle die great food dann gibt er
kelsey ein stück ab aber nur 1 den rest
behält er das ist eine kiwi eine kiwi
zwei kiwis chelsea teil die kiwis in
zwei hälften und löffelt sie aus die
kiwis ist etwas bitter das ist eine
zitrone eine zitrone zwei zitronen
janosch liebt zitronen mt
wenn er besonders waage möglich ist ist
der zitronen auch pro
das war unser video für heute wenn ihr
lust habt könnt ihr die german gerne
unterstützen und ein patriot werden
darüber freuen wir uns sehr ihr könnt
auch easy german abonnieren
darüber freuen wir uns auch wahnsinnig
wenn sie und mich bedanken sich fürs
zuschauen
tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche